באנו לעבור לא באנו להצטל יופי שאנשים באו
להצטלם חבל שהסיכון לחימה של החטיבה היה
כבר יאללה רצים מה
מה הזכרת שבוע הבא ביום רביעי מ בבוקר עד
7 בערב ערב תשעה באב
ממש יאללה
אומר שאתה לא צריך לצורצים
נגמר
זהו זה מצולם
לא
הממפה שהבן שלך דרוזי אתה לא צריך
הלך
מג'יד אני מת עליך
ישב פה אחי שעתיים וחצי
אפשר ליפ
איפה היינו לזה לזה שאני חייב להתקדם אדבר
איתך אחרי זה
איפה היינו
היינו בסיפור של ה של הביפור
ו
אז חטיבת גבעתי יוצאת להתקפה לאיינתה
משימה בסוף לשלוט מבצעית
ממזרח למערב על הכפר בינ בינבל א יש רכס
באמצע בין לבנ'בל יש רכס נוסף שהוא נקרא
רכס המרחיצה
שאנחנו יוצאים להתקפה אנחנו יוצאים להתקפה
על רכס על רכז של הינתה התקפה בשני צירים
גדוד 52 וסיערת במאמץ אחד גדוד 424 ו607
במאמץ שני
שאנחנו יוצאים להתקפה הזאתי תחושת הביטחון
והמסוגלות אחרי אלכי מגבוהה שאנחנו אנחנו
יושבים לפני זה ומדברים על המפקדים אנחנו
אומרים הדבר החשוב זה לבוא צנועים לקרב.
עשינו קרב אחד מוצלח, תחושת ההצלחה פה היא
חשובה אבל הצניעות פה היא חשובה. ולבוא
שאנחנו מבינים, באים חזק, מבינים את השטח,
מבינים את האויב, אבל באים צלויים ולא
מזלזלים א במערכת האויב שמולנו.
ההתקדמות הרבה יותר מורכבת. כבר אנחנו
מדברים על 10 קילומטרים של ציר עוד פעם
בקרקע של בוצית אנחנו חורף בלבנון א
והתקפה קוראת הרבה יותר טוב מ שאנחנו
יכולים לדמיין ועוד פעם אנחנו מגיעים לשטח
הבנוי אחרי לילה ארוך שהתקלויות והרבה תמס
ומוצאים את עצמנו אחרי יום שבדיעבד אני
יודע שאף אחד לא האמין שזה באמת מה שיקרה
בתוך יום אחד לשלוט עליינתה לשלוט מבצעית
אה על א בינג'בל ותוך יום אחד למרות
אתגרים של קרקע של אויב של המון פרטי תמס
של פצועים מהתמס כתיבת גיבעתי מתמקמת על
בעצם על על רכס היינתה וזה מה שפותח את
הדלת לבינג'בל השליטה על איינתה פותחת את
הדלת לבינג'בל גם בשליטה לכיוון קונין
שמצפון שזה הכפרים שבעצם הם העתודות של
בינג'בל וגם השליטה מגבוה לנמוכה לבינג'בל
במשך שבוע משימת החטיבה לייצר את התנאים
להתקפה על בינץ' שבוע שלם שמה שעושים זה
להתחיל לפתוח צירים להתחיל
משימת החטיבה היא לפתוח א היא במשך שבוע
משימת החטיבה היא להכין את ההתקפה לבינץ'
ולייצר את התנאים המבצעים
בין אם זה לפתוח צירים בין אם זה להכשיר
את הקרקע בין אם זה להשמיד אויב בין אם זה
לפשות בין אם זה לנטרל אויב ושאנחנו
יוצאים לבנג'בל כל האצבעות של רכס עינתה
אחרי שהם תוארו ובעצם יש לנו שליטה של 180
מעלות על בינג'ב יש לנו אויב שחטף במשך
שבוע אינסוף התקפות יש לנו אין כמות הפעלת
האש מטורפת ובעצם התנאים המבצעים לרשותנו
הדבר היחידי שחסר זה פתיחת הדרך לבינג'בל
גדוד 424 מקבל את המשימה לייצר מפרק מה זה
מפרק מפרק זה גדוד שמתקדם
ומשימתו במשך השבוע שאנחנו מכשירים את
השטח למעלה הוא פותח את הדרך לכיוון
בינ'בל בפעולה הזאתי 42 יצרו את הדרך
לבינ'בל 42 פתחו את הדרך לבינ'בל ביצירת
המפרק ויצרו שם את התנאים בידדו את הקסבה
של בינ'בל ודרכם החטיבה יוצאת להתקפה
יום לפני ההתקפה אנחנו במעבר עוגדות
ההתקפה לבינ'בן לרכס המחיצה התקפה לרכס
המחיצה מאושרת מול עוגדה 91 באותו לילה
אנחנו עוברים לעוגדה 98 ונ נכנסים לדין
ודברים האם נכון לצאת להתקפה בוקר ומחורת
האם נכון לשנות את התוכניות לאור זה
שעברנו עוגדה האם השפעה האם יש קיימת
השפעה של התקדמות חטיבת הצנחנים ממערב
למזרח ואנחנו מתעקשים
חטיבה מתעקשת אל מול ה אל מול העוגדה
חטיבת גבעת היא לא משנה תוכניות ואנחנו
נצמדים לתכנון המקורי והיוצאים להתקפה א
מחר בבוקר כמו שתכננו
על רכס המחיצה
שהתכנון של החטיבה גדוד 52 מוביל את
ההתקפה אחרי שגדוד 424 יצרו את המפרק 52
נכנס ביחד עם סיירת ונכנסים לאכס המחיצה
התכנון להגיע עד מערב עידן נוחנה זה בעצם
חצי הדרך של המחיצה רגע לפני הבתי חולים
בתי החולים זה הבית חולים הממשלתי והבית
חולים של סל החנדור שתי בתי חולים שנמצאים
על רכס המחיצה. צריך להגיד שחטיבת הקומנדו
במקביל בנועל קרב סדור על אותם יעדים
ואנחנו א המשימה שלנו להיכנס לרכס המחיצה
להגיע עד הצומת בעצם עד המערב עידן נוחנה
ומשם לאפשר להם להיכנס לבתי החולים. בבוקר
ההתקפה שאנחנו יוצאים ההתקפה הולכת כמו
שתכננו. אני ארוץ על זה בסדר? ברור עזור
לא ספ את זה אני יוצה את התגובות
מעולה
תוך כדי ההתקפה על על א תוך כדי ההתקפה על
רכס המחיצה יול מגד 52 עולה מול המחת
ואומר לו קודקוד כאן לוקו המחבלים בורחים
וזה בעצם נקודת המפנה שאנחנו מבינים
שתמונת האויב שונה מ שחשבנו אנחנו דמיינו
את העורך את האויב נערך ומתבצר על רכס
המחיצה ובעצם אנחנו מגלים שהאויב עובר
מקרב הגנב לקרב נסיגה והוא בורח באופן לא
מאורגן. הפה שלו
התרסק לגמרי. כל מערכי ההגנה התרסקו לגמרי
על ידי ההתקפה המהירה שגדוד 52. ויול עולה
בקשר ואומר אנחנו יכולים לצאת קדימה.
והחטיבה בנועל הקרב נערכת מראש לדפה
הזאתי. וברגע שהמנצה הזאתי באה ממגד שנמצא
בשטח ואומר אני מזהה אויב בורחת גבעתי
אומר לו אתה רשאי לצאת לבית החולים
הממשלתי
זו נקודת המפנה בקרב על בינג'בין נקודת
המפנה שאנחנו מבינים שהאויב עובר מהגנה
לנסיגה ושאנחנו עובדרים מהתקפה לרדיפה
חטיבת גיבעתי עוברת לצורת קרב רדיפה
פותחים קדימה גדוד 52 מסתער קדימה בעקב
שלו סיירת מתקדמת מעבל לו התודה ובהמשך גם
כן היא מצטערת שאנחנו תופסים את האויב לא
מוכן לא ארוך שכל העמדות כל המערכי הגנה
שהוא בונה פשוט מתפרקים לו בין האצבעות
והוא מוצא את עצמו חסר עונים ושתה חסר
עונים אתה עושה טעויות ושהאויב עושה
טעויות אנחנו מנצלים אותם ובאותו לילה
באותו יום מכסלים 25 פעילים על ידי
כוחותינו אויב שרואים בעיניים שהיא מכוסה
על ידי כוחותינו שתי בתי חולים אחד נכנסים
סוגרים עליו ונכנסים בבית חולים של תי
הבית חולים השני סוגרים עליו לא נכנסים
אבל סוגרים עליו והאויב יוצא מבפנים
והורגים שם גם מחבלים בכניסה לבית החולים
וגדוד שקד שבעצם מתחיל לקדוח לכיוון הקסבה
באותו היום ואנחנו מבינים שהיום הזה
שהמעבר של ניצול ההצלחה ומעבר מהתקפה
לרדלייפה זה היום שבינ'בל הוכרע
זה נושא הפרק הבנת
זה מוקד התחקיר גם של החטיבה כן
זה נושא הפרק אני כל הזמן חיפתי אף אחד מה
אף אחד מהם
לא היה לי קוד 52 היה לי רק את מג'ק כאילו
ואת א איך קוראים לו לא
נכון זה מה שאני אומר הוא לא הצליח להביא
לי ואני כל הם בראש שלי אני אומר לו אחי
אין לי סיפור אין לי סיפור אין לי סיפור
אז אתה רוצה שאני אתעכב על זה
לא רגע יש לי כמה ש תיקח אותי שמה גם אחת
צריך לספר את זה הנה על רב
בסדר נו מה אתה
איך מגיבים הרמה ממונה
לא אבל אני לא שור לשרוף אני יכול לשרוף
מה לשר
מה
אוקיי בסדר
שהוא סגר את הזה שהוא אמר להם
כן לספר כאילו לא
ברור מה Да.